thousands of years well really probably
millions of years our ancestors have
looked up at the sky and wondered what's
up there and they've also have started
to wonder hmm could we be alone in this
planet now I'm fortunate that I get to
pay get paid to actually ask some of
those questions and sort of bad news for
you your tax dollars are paying me to
try to answer some of those questions
but then about ten years ago I was told
I mean asked if I would start to look at
the technology to help get us off planet
and so that's what I'm going to talk to
you about today
so plane to the local crowd this is what
it looks like in your day to day life in
Boston but as you start to go off planet
things look very very different so there
we are hovering above the WGBH studios
and here's a very famous picture of the
earth rise from the moon and you can see
the earth starting to recede and then
what I love is this picture that was
taken from the surface of Mars looking
back at the earth can anyone find the
earth I'm gonna help you out a little
mm-hmm yeah the point of showing this is
that when people start to go to Mars
they're not going to be able to keep
calling in and being micromanaged the
way people on space station are they're
gonna have to be independent so even
though they're up there they're gonna be
all sorts of things that they're gonna
need just like people on earth need
things like oh transportation like
support food clothing and so on but
unlike on earth they are also going to
need oxygen they're gonna have to deal
with about a third of the gravity that
we have here they're gonna have to worry
about habitats power heat light and
radiation protection something that we
don't actually worry about nearly as
much on the earth because we had this
beautiful atmosphere and magnetosphere
the problem with that is that we also
have a lot of constraints
the biggest one for us is up mass and
the number that I've used for years is
it costs about ten thousand dollars to
launch a can of coke into low-earth
orbit the problem is there you are
with ten thousand dollars later and
you're still in low-earth orbit you're
not even at the Moon or Mars or anything
else so you're going to have to try to
figure out how to keep the mass as low
as possible so you don't have to launch
it but on top of that cost issue with
the mass you also have problems of
storage and flexibility and reliability
you can't just get there and say oops I
forgot to bring because amazon.com just
does not deliver to Mars so you better
be prepared so what is the solution for
this and I'm going to propose to you for
the rest of this talk that the solution
actually is life and when you start to
look at life as a technology you realize
that's it that's exactly what we needed
this plant here like every person here
and every one of your dogs and cats and
plants and so on all started as a single
cell so imagine you're starting is a
very low-mass object and then growing
into something a good deal bigger now my
hero Charles Darwin of course reminds us
that there's no such thing as a designer
in biology but what if what if we now
have the technology to design biology
maybe even design Oh whole new
life-forms that can do things for us
that we couldn't have imagined otherwise
so years ago I was asked to start to
sell this program and I was doing that I
was put in front of a panel at NASA as
you might sort of imagine a bunch of
people in suits and white shirts and
pencil protectors and I did this sort of
you know crazy wild this is all that you
know the next great thing and I thought
they would be blowing over and instead
the chairman of the committee just
looked at me straight in the eye and
said so what's the big idea so
okay you want Star Trek we'll do Star
Trek and so let me tell you what the big
idea is we have used organisms to make
biomaterials for years so here's a great
picture taken outside of Glasgow and you
can see lots of great biomaterials there
there are trees that you could use to
build houses they're sheep where they
could get your wool from you could get
leather from the sheep I just quickly
glanced around the room I bet there's no
one in this room that doesn't have some
kind of animal or plant product on them
some kind of biomaterial but you know
what we're not going to take sheep and
trees and stuff to Mars that's nuts
because the up-mass problem but we are
going to take things like this
this is bacillus subtlest those white
dots that you see are spores this
happens to be a bacterium that can form
incredibly resistance force and when I
say incredibly resistant they've proven
themselves so a subtlest spores have
been flowing on what was called LDAP
long-duration exposure facility for
almost six years and some of them
survived that in space unbelievable a
lot better than any of us can do so why
not just take the capabilities like to
make wood or to make wool or spider silk
or whatever and put them in bacillus
subtlest spores and take those with you
off planet so what are you gonna do when
you're off planet here's an iconic
picture of Buzz Aldrin looking back at
the Eagle when he landed oh it was
almost 50 years ago on the surface of
the Moon now if you're gonna go to the
moon for three days and you're the first
person to set foot yeah you can live in
a tin can but you wouldn't want to do
that for say a year and a half so I did
actually a calculation being in
California I looked at what the average
size of a cell at Alcatraz is and I
couldn't use for you the volume in the
Eagle there in the lunar module was
about the size of a cell at Alcatraz if
it were only five feet high so
incredibly cramped living quarters you
just can't ask a human to stay in there
for long periods of time so why not take
these biomaterials and make something so
an image that colleague of mine who's an
architect Chris Mauer on his done of
what we've been proposing and we'll get
to the point of why I've been standing
up here holding something that looks
like a dried sandwich this whole lecture
so we propose that the solution to the
habitat problem on Mars could just
simply lie in a fungus so I've now
probably going to turn off everyone from
ever eating a mushroom again so let's
let's talk about fungi for a second so
you're probably familiar with this
fruiting body of the fungus that's the
mushroom but what we're interested in
actually is what's beneath the surface
there the mycelium which are these root
hairlike structures that are really the
main part of the mushroom well it turns
out you can take those there's a
micrograph I did and you can put them in
a mold and give them a little food and
it doesn't take much you can grow these
things on sawdust and so on so this
piece here was growing on sawdust and
that mycelium then will fill that
structure to make something we've
actually tried going mycelium on Mars
similar simulant so no one's actually
going to the surface of Mars but this is
simulating surface of Mars and you can
see those hair like my Celia out there
it's really amazing stuff how strong can
you make these things well you know I
could give you numbers and tests and so
on but I think that's probably the best
way to describe it there's one of my
students proving that you can do this
I'm to do this then you've got to figure
out how to put it in context how's this
actually gonna happen I mean this is a
great idea Lynne but how are you gonna
get from here to there so what we're
saying is you grow up the mycelium in
the lab for example and then you fill up
a little structure maybe a house like
structure that's tiny that is maybe a
double bag sort of plastic thing like an
inflatable I sort of think l.l.bean when
I see this and then you put in a rocket
ship and you send it off to Mars rocket
lands you release the bag and you add a
little water and while I you've got your
habitats you know how cool would that be
and the beauty of that is you don't have
to take something pre-built
so our estimates are that we could save
ninety percent of the mass that mass is
currently proposing by taking up a big
steel structure if we actually grow it
on-site so let me give you another big
idea what about digital information
what's really interesting is you have a
physical link to your parents and they
have a physical link to their parents
and so on all the way back to the origin
of life you have never broken that
continuum but the fact is that we can do
that today so we have students every day
in our labs students in Boston even do
this that make up DNA sequences and they
hit the send button and they send into
their local DNA synthesis company now
once you've made that physical link to
break that physical link where you're
sending it across town it doesn't matter
if you're sending it across the Charles
River or if you're sending that
information to Mars you've broken that
physical link so then once you're on
Mars or across the river or wherever you
can take that digital information
synthesize the physical DNA put it maybe
in another organism and voila you've got
new capabilities there so again you've
broken that physical link that's huge
what about chemistry biology does
chemistry for us on earth and again has
for literally thousands of years
I bet virtually everyone in this room is
eatin something today that has been made
by biology doing chemistry let me give
you a big hint there what about another
idea what about using DNA itself to make
a wire it's again we're trying to
miniaturize everything DNA is really
cheap strawberries have a gazillion
amount of DNA you know you could take a
strawberry with you isolate the DNA and
one of my students has figured out a way
to take DNA and tweak it a little bit so
that you can incorporate silver atoms in
very specific places thus making an
electrical wire how cool is that
so while we're on the subject of metals
we're gonna need to use metals for
things like integrated circuits probably
we're gonna want it for some structures
and so on and things like integrated
circuits ultimately go bad we could talk
a lot about that but I'm gonna I'm gonna
leave it at that that they do
Oh bad and so where are you gonna get
those medals yeah you could try to mine
them with heavy equipment but you get
that up-mass problem I always tell
people the best way to find the medals
for a snoo cellphone isn't a dead cell
phone so what if you take biology as the
technology to get these metals out and
how do you do this well take a look at
the back of a vitamin bottle and you'll
get an idea of all the sorts of metals
that we actually use in our bodies so we
have a lot of proteins as well as other
organisms that can actually specifically
bind metals so what if we now take those
proteins and maybe attach them to this
fungal mycelium and make a filter so we
can start to pull those metals out in a
very specific way without big mining
equipment and even better we've actually
done a proof of concept where we've then
taken those metals that we pulled out
with proteins and reprinted an
integrated circuit using a plasma
printer you know again how cool
electricity I was asked by the head of
one of the the NASA centers if you could
ever take chemical energy and turn that
into electrical energy well the great
news is is not just the electric eel
that does it everybody in this room who
is still alive and functioning is doing
that part of the food that you've eaten
today is going to operate the nerve
cells in your body but even other
organisms non-sentient ones are creating
electrical energy even bacteria some
bacteria are very good at making little
wires so if we can harvest that ability
of turning chemical energy into
electrical energy again how cool would
that be so here's some of the big ideas
we talked about let me try one more life
2.0 so for example all of the sugars in
our body are right-handed why shouldn't
we make an organism with left-handed
sugars why not make an organism that can
do things that no organism can do today
so organisms normally have evolved to
live in very specific environments so
here's this lion cup literally up a tree
and I took a picture I'm a bit later and
it's a lot happier when he was down on
the ground
so organisms are designed for specific
environments but what if you can go back
to that idea of synthetic biology and
tweak them around so here's one of our
favorite places in Yellowstone National
Park this is octopus Springs if you tilt
your head a little bit it sort of looks
like a body and and tentacles coming out
it's above the boiling temperature of
water those organisms that you see on
the edge and the colors actually match
the temperatures that are there very
very high temperature thermophiles so
why not take organisms that can live
extremes whether it's high temperature
low temperature low pH or high pH or
high salt or high levels of radiation
and take some of those capabilities and
put it into other organisms this is a
project that my students have called I
love this the hell cell and so we've
done that we've taken organisms and sort
of tweaked them and push them the edges
and this is important for getting us off
planet and also for understanding what
life is like in the universe so let me
give you just a couple of final thoughts
first is this whole idea that we have
all these needs for human settlement off
planet that are in some ways exactly
like we have on the earth that we need
the food and we need the shelter and so
on but we have very very different
constraints of this up-mass problem and
the reliability and the flexibility and
so on but because we have these
constraints that you don't have here
where you might have to think about the
indigenous petrochemical industry or
whatever you now have constraints that
have to unleash creativity and once you
unleash this creativity because you have
the new constraints you're forcing
game-changing technological advances
that you wouldn't have gotten any other
way finally we have to think a little
bit is it a good idea to take her around
with life well the the sort of easy
answer to that is that probably no one
in the room keeps a wolf cub at home but
you might have a puppy or a dog
you probably didn't eat Tia sente this
summer but you ate corn we've been doing
genetic modification with organisms for
literally 10,000 or more years this is a
different approach but to say all the
sudden humans should never touch an
organism it's kind of silly because the
we have that capability now to do things
that are far more beneficial for the
planet Earth and for life beyond that
and so then the question is should we
and of course I feel that not only
should we at least for getting off earth
but actually if we don't use synthetic
biology we will never solve this up-mass
problem so once you think of life is a
technology you've got the solution and
so with that I'd like to finish by the
way I always finish and say ad astra
which means to the stars
thank you very much Boston
[Applause]